and we're live
we've been live so i got to tell you
crazy story what happened to you by the
way episode number 63 this morning i'm
driving i rarely do this
drive i'm driving to the office
and i'm watching videos which you
shouldn't be doing i don't recommend it
to anybody i'm watching videos while i'm
driving
and i'm getting to the right lane which
is the lane to go into
the office and i cut somebody off and
this person gets upset at me
and i put my hand up to say hey you know
i i think i just cut somebody
the old coat of the room yeah i always
do that because i've done it millions of
times
and the person i cut off was our friend
right here
i cut off vanessa and i'm like is that
vanessa
i think it's vanessa because she shook
her head she went like tell me you're
doing this
and then she slowed down and i went past
i'm like okay i think she's still
sitting in the car because she doesn't
want to think
i got a final but i knew was i came and
told you about it today so there you go
no altercation no no there was no
altercation what happened when your boss
and ceo
here's the challenges i like driving
yeah i actually enjoy you know how
there's people that enjoy
i enjoy driving matter of fact i've been
looking for a good stick shift to buy
a sports car stick shift and you know
they're doing all these automatic stuff
everything's going more to automatic
automatic i want
to know the best stick shift car
race car to buy what the hell are you
going to do driving [ __ ]
what are you going to do with the stick
shift tell me you get driven in
but you drive home because you'll be
more relaxed on the way home maybe just
do some calls
you could be you know really productive
on the way by the way i always thought a
great invention would be
a secondary horn right because you got
the main horn yeah like if there's just
a little thing that goes on someone
maybe emerges and you just want to get
their attention just a little tap
just a light little thing right so
there's no road rage secondary secondary
horn you got to have two horns
adam likes the old-school horns
remember those horns very loud
mini coopers yes i used to think i can
see you in a porsche i can also see you
in a mini cooper though
okay all right mazda miata maybe
convertible type
you know what i can see you always feel
like you know what i can see you in in
the back seat of a car
yeah i don't want you driving it's been
big i think you're
established you should not be driving
and the closer we get to it i think i'm
more convinced you're right
everything cleaning once you realize how
much more productive you'd be
for that 25 minutes probably you get
another video shot i love driving guys
that's my biggest challenge i love to
drive
anyways okay so let's get into it we got
a lot of stuff to cover here
um a couple months ago was it two months
ago when we were having the episode with
uh
byron udell was in and we talked about
taxes and then i said i'm gonna go do
research on taxes do you remember that
you did i did notes
you know 56 this is just the stuff that
made it here
we shot a tax episode okay for me you
have
no idea how excited i am to launch this
video matter of fact i got some fun
facts for you
i got some phone calls are they fun i
got some fun facts for you i'm actually
curious to know what you'll say about it
okay
you know some of them so some of them
you can play along okay but maybe others
can play it on can you tell me who
invented
the irs who was the founder of the iowa
i'm gonna go with ben franklin he had so
many great inventions let me go with
benjamin okay so benjamin benjamin
are you ready to be shocked folks if
you're listening to this don't google it
don't search it i'm actually asking and
i'm curious to know what you'll say
who during which president's
administration do you think the irs
was founded under during which president
administration do you think the irs was
founded on
my guest yesterday was very close you
said grant
i said jesus christ yes you know who it
is no abraham lincoln wow
is that one baby civil war abraham
lincoln came up
and they founded the irs and they said
we're going to raise it was the first
time ever we had federal income taxes
lincoln got up said listen to pay off
the civil war we have to raise taxes
they came up with federal income taxes
in 1862 but they said
when we pay it off guess what we'll get
away with the taxes
do you think it's time not yet right and
years later when they paid it off
the taxes went away is that not crazy
exactly whoa
that's exactly it and they went away
because they said we only raised taxes
to pay off the war
and it was a three percent tax where
people making between
six hundred dollars to ten thousand
dollars and it was a five percent tax
for people making over
ten thousand dollars it was essentially
the first progressive tax that we had in
america
under a lincoln administration right but
it did go away here's another fun fact
for you
war the idea of war and taxes there are
so many correlations between
war and taxes property taxes just so you
know property taxes
is the byproduct of war of 1812.
interesting
the way they collected money to pay off
for the war of 1812 the star-spangled
banner
was by you know coming out with a
property tax
did not know that i don't know if you
knew you knew that i know obviously you
pay a lot of attention when it comes on
to tax time you're in the insurance
business
you so you know a lot about it but
property taxes came from war of 1812.
here's another one for you how many
military bases
foreign military bases do you think the
u.s has
i'm going to take a wild guess i'm going
to say 45. 45. folks if you're listening
how many military bases
do you think the u.s has foreign okay
kai you know this number sam do you know
this number how many military bases
do you think there are foreign u.s
military foreign you said 45
i'm going with that what do you think
the number is how many u.s
foreign military bases folks if you
think you know the answer
comment below you will also be shocked
here in a minute how many
50 51 what do you think
foreign military bases oh i'll go with
55. 55 what are you going to do you
spawn wheel of fortune
53 they're great training off my
prediction you're ready what it is
that's like price is right
by the way prices you ready 800
whoa in 71 countries now here's a trick
question to everybody you ready
everybody's putting you somebody put a
thousand who put a thousand greatest
ever put a thousand
mark buchi put 350. chicken diner 13 put
800 he probably
searched it but you know what that's a
good guess as well if you got it right
aratus i've solely put
60 trillion okay
so i'm glad to hear that it's a high
number
if the us has 800 military bases in 71
countries
how many military bases foreign military
bases do you think china has
how many think china has oh god i want
you to actually guess this
i want to i want to guess it's fewer i
want to say 300.
okay what do you think it is you guys
want to take a wild guess let me put it
through this but i guarantee you're not
going to get it right
i'm trying to help you here yeah so you
got to give a crazy number
fifteen hundred okay two thousand okay
let's say two thousand years one they
have one
they only have one i knew it was like
one guy can you pull up the only foreign
military base china has
and where it's at folks this is like
apps people
people can't even comment on this stuff
it's mind-blowing when you think about
this
china foreign military bases okay go to
where it's at
okay the djibouti is what it's called
exactly yeah they like djibouti that's
exactly where it is can you go to the
military but
where djiboutian so people where
djiboutians go to maps okay just go to
maps
go to djibouti right there it is the
only
foreign military base in the chokehold
of the suez canal
that is the only military base china has
now here's another question for you
you ready yeah we're working with very
poorly
okay okay by the way you and i were
doing poorly i just so happened to have
gotten this research because i would
have never guessed these numbers right
here's the next one
combine russia okay russia france
and britain okay okay three of the
superpowers in the world
how many military bases do they have
foreign between
russia france and britain do you know
this or
i don't know okay so you can guess on
this one how many do they have i
i'm gonna guess this is not china so
this is a different number i just want
everybody to know this
combined combine combine all coming
together i'm gonna say it's a very low
number
dominated by russia i'm going to say 16.
okay what do you think it is
i'm going with a niner 90. nine
niner okay nine what do you guys say uh
i'm gonna say
five five okay
[Laughter]
it's actually 30. 30. it's actually 30.
those combined together you have 30.
are you not blown away by this this is
absolutely you say
less is everywhere us is controversial
800 million people for a while
because we're policing the world that's
why but you're paying for
exactly what you're paying now that's
the question and i'm a military guy i'm
a pro military guy i'm an army guy
is that a good thing or a bad thing
there's that many military bases here's
what's the point you know what happens
when you're involved in too many uh
people's
marital problems you know you know once
i become an enemy eventually
that's a person right yeah so what you
know like those moms that are too
over control how's this going how's that
going eventually just stay
the hell out of it you know u.s is
starting to become a little bit too
800 foreign military bases 800 a lot
it's incomprehensible you know watch
what china is doing so china they have
one
specifically one why intentionally
because they want to make sure they're
getting their oil because most of it all
comes from there so they need that part
right
but do you know what they're doing with
the other money u.s is spending fighting
wars the old school way from the 56
70s all they're doing is bio
cyber hack they're studying all of those
ways and they're using those resources
so take creating
viruses doing their thing fauci said it
could be possible apparently
he's a my apologies
so the point is so the point is so
that's one area when you when you link
military bases and taxes they actually
go together here's another crazy thing
for you you ready yeah
okay this whole concept about
withholding taxes
right yesterday we're talking like it's
not really a big deal we're like we
gotta kind of come up with a better way
of putting it
withholding taxes how long has that
thing been around withholding taxes
in the first time ever where we well
withheld taxes
who was it under first time we ever win
that's easy that's easy that's like 40
50 years old some democratic president
give me a kennedy
okay lincoln was the first person that
came out with a withholding taxes
you gave essentially what they did is
they made the employer the tax collector
the employer became the tax collector to
see what they can do with the taxes
rather than the irs being a tax
collector
because they wanted to pay off the civil
war which they did and the american
people were okay with that because it
eventually what
stopped yeah it eventually stopped okay
but 1862 they don't have the adp system
they don't have all the system that they
have today
it was simple the employer kind of paid
it to the government right now fast
forward so that went away
years later guess who made it official
to help
tax withholding system become a law easy
lyndon maine's johnson okay you know who
it is who milton friedman huh
out of all the a republican a republican
so you know you know what he said
libertarian republican what was it i
would say he's republican i would say
he's republican by the way later on in
life when he did this it was in 1943 he
was younger
he helped the reason why he says because
we have to pay off the world war ii
money we just didn't have the money for
it right so they went from having
this is actually a very interesting fact
here they went from in 1939 how many
people in america do you think filed
taxes in
1939 how many americans filed taxes in
1939 u.s population at the time was 131
million yeah
20 million it's 50 million for four
million people wow
there they go three years later they go
three years later
41 million they went from revenues being
900 million and 39
to five years later and 40 and 43 being
41 uh 43 billion dollars so think about
the amount of money they raised yeah but
that probably won world war ii
because of it well then but here's what
happened the difference is when it comes
down to taxes the following here's the
difference the difference is the fact
that
when they came up with the taxes in 1862
under lincoln they said it's going to go
away
under wilson under woodrow wilson they
came out with the 16th amendment
the 16th amendment allowed people to
make income taxes or law because before
it was tough
you couldn't do it the 16th amendment
allowed politicians to go back because
there was this one case
kind 1894 i want to say charles pollock
against farmers company of 1894
put charles [ __ ] i think it's versus
farmers of 1894 i think something like
that
type that in uh farmers okay there you
go click on that uh
1895 i was one off so charles pollock
versus
pollock versus the farmer's loan and
trust of 1895
when they came up with this this they
were trying to tax the u.s population
four percent two percent
on four thousand dollars or more of
income he said no you can't do that
again it's against the constitution
the guy went and fought supreme court
defending him saying you're right
the constitution says you cannot just
tax people income taxes
so later on under wilson they made it a
law the 16th amendment allowed the
government to just impose
impose any kind of taxes right now
here's a kicker
in 1913 when the woodrow wilson new
amendment came up
uh what happened to world war one when
did world war one start
1917. okay we got involved around 1917
1919.
do you know the taxes when woodrow
wilson first introduced the progressive
taxes
it was one percent for anybody making
zero to twenty thousand dollars
it was two percent for twenty to fifty
thousand dollars and it went all the way
up the top marginal tax rate
in 1913 was seven percent seven
percent not 70 percent four years later
the top marginal tax rate went to 67
percent
and you want to know something crazy
from 1917
till 1965
the top line top marginal tax rate never
went below 67 percent it went
all the way up to 94 is what happened to
taxes anyways i mean
the whole concept of taxes yeah
mind-boggling when you study what
happened here can i give you one number
sure okay if you don't know this jump in
if you do maybe
don't but how many new irs agents does
joe biden want to hire
three times what we have today there's a
number exactly do you know what it is i
mean this is unbelievable
87 000 irs agents man they are going to
be going nuts
you know they're they want to dig back
on all the the other tax evasion that
they
feel that people were guilty of as far
as high net worth people so they're
calling after that money trillion people
that's a lot
all to do audits i mean they're going to
be auditing like crazy couple
so what what were your biggest takeaways
from what i understand
the tax correlation between taxes and
war yeah
can you pull up that link about who's
paying more taxes the one percent the
five percent the 10 percent if you know
which one i'm talking about guys send it
to you
number two it doesn't seem like this is
a democratic high taxation thing it
seems like republicans were taxing two
yeah but based on what you're saying the
difference is republicans did taxes
assuming it's temporary democrats made
it permanent
that's the difference and for specific
costs yeah so so lincoln said hey
let's raise taxes to pay off civil war
democrats said uh-huh
socialist labor party the populist party
the democratic party what if we can make
this permanent and they did
when milton friedman agreed to the tax
withholding system the only reason he
did
was because he thought it was to pay off
the world war ii debt that we had
he didn't think was going to be
permanent obviously he helped it become
permanent before he died in his memoir
he talked about one of the biggest
mistakes he ever made is helping pass
the tax withholding system really and he
said it was going to happen with or
without him but he helped that
can you pull up the numbers here kai
take a look at this so you know how we
talk about who pays the most taxes in
america you know we say
that one person is not paying taxes
anymore this is an interesting chart if
you make it bigger and flip the focus on
them
uh sam so this is the number of
percentage of taxpayers
the bottom 50 percent look how big it is
right
then you get the top 25 to 50 percent
then you got the top ten look at the
bottom one percent
very small community right very small
community now
who pays the biggest amount of taxes in
america look at the right
the one percent pays nearly the
same amount of taxes as the bottom 50
pays look at the one percent right there
and then go to the next chart go to the
next chart that we had go down i think
it's a couple more
keep going keep going keep going is it
above it or below maybe it was above
that guy right there
make it a little smaller this shows over
the years
is the one percent paying more or less
taxes look at that
all the way to the left it shows you
from 1980
to today as the year goes by the one
percent keeps paying
more and more and more taxes
the top five percent is also paying more
and more if you're into 10 percent
you're the same nothing's changed for
the top 10 percent
the top 25 percent it's getting lower
the top 50
is getting lower and a bottom 50 it's
definitely getting lower so this kind of
tells when you get into it and you take
a deep dive
into the tax topic you realize it is not
as black and white as people talk about
it it's not like hey you know
republicans do this democrats do this no
republicans also raise taxes
but there was an intention behind it
with the payoff the democrats looked at
that and capitalized and let's make this
permanent so again
did you get the feeling after doing the
video that they could easily simplify
this or this is
okay i think i think one of the biggest
one of the biggest reasons why i did
this video is to get people to just
question
like what i want to see is the following
right now look we got 1652 people
watching by the way let me just announce
this right now here's what we're doing
today
we got a couple new ideas that we came
up with anybody that puts a super chat
whether it's a dollar
five dollars ten dollars a hundred
dollars whatever it may be five hundred
dollars
by the end i'm gonna pick one or two or
three or five
best super chat quotes or questions that
if we involve you
and we're gonna pay you back 10 times
what you put in super chat
for example you put 10 bucks what's 10
times 10 we're going to wire you
100 bucks you put 100 bucks if it's the
best super chat question
we're going to wire you back what do you
call it a thousand dollars game because
when this is not a money-making machine
for us we're we're doing this podcast
because we're enjoying this
but at the same time we want more people
involved look at the 690 people on it
right okay
do you know how many people like this
video goes out in valuetainment but it's
got three million subscribers
how many views you think the tax video
is going to get honestly
it's going to be one of those that
people share right now i don't think so
oh really that's the problem what i
think i think now if i put a video
of me you know going out there and
jumping out of a plane
it's probably going to get a million
views if i put a video with me and
couple mobsters
it's probably going to get 100 million
views if i put a video about taxes and a
history of taxes
it's going to get probably 100 000 to
200 000 views over the next 12 months
why because
nobody cares nobody cares about
taxes they're entertained they're
watching netflix they're watching sports
there's a very small community of people
that are sitting there saying this
matters here's a pr here's a challenge
though here's a good good news there
you know what the good news is if
charles [ __ ] could do what he did
and supreme court can go in his favor if
a story like this would lincoln which
you're a smart guy you went to a good
university
you did not know you're a smart guy you
didn't know i'm a pretty well-read guy i
don't know this kind of stuff
i'm sitting here saying kai has read
half the books in the world he didn't
know any of this stuff right
we're sitting here going through this
date and we're like i never i never knew
about that
iris got started on their lincoln i
never knew about that you mean to tell
me
it was only for 10 years and then you
went away with it yeah because they
wanted to pay off the civil war
i never knew about that that's what
needs to be talked about the american
people need to sit there and say
wait what you mean to tell me federal
income taxes went away
yes how because we were living off of
excise and tariff taxes
that's what we were living off of right
it was 50 cents
per ton of goods coming from out of
the states foreign 50 cents per ton
and it was six cents per anything that
was being uh exchanged within the states
so there are ways for us to change our
taxes where people from the outside are
paying there are ways we can change our
taxes
and decrease it but right now
everybody's just kind of looking away
being entertained and taxes keep going
up and up and up and up and up and we
have no clue what the hell is going on
yeah but
it's so many social programs that once
they have the money coming in they just
find new ways to spend it
that's the difference now right that's
why these things will never be lowered
once the politicians get a handle what
do you mean by social proof well i just
mean all the free
all the money that's going out all the
free money that's going on look what's
happened the last
few weeks so i mean that's where the tax
money's going that's why they want to
keep raising the taxes it's not like
they're looking to cut spending
cut anything in the budget you know
where the majority of our uh
us budget goes the majority of our
budget are you going to say military it
is the defense
it is yeah well defense is not even in
the top five oh okay
what is it number one is social security
no no no number two entitlement programs
uh that titleman's not even in the top
20. i'm just saying where are
actual 20 trillion dollar budget goes
where it's actually going the big three
social security medicare can you pull
that okay
so we can look at this if you look at if
you google uh
us budget breakdown um by far and away
it's social security
medicare medicaid it's not even close
and then after those big three things
you have um paying off our
there's one that has like a pie chart
kind of exactly
pie chart go to the pie chart and then
you have
just paying off our debt paying off our
debt is probably
seven to eight percent then you have the
military and then all the social pro
programs that everyone thinks about look
health care defensive social security
defenses that might i think that might
not even be right go to a different one
point is the vast majority of our budget
goes to
old and sick people that's that's the
united states go up a little bit
discretionary spending so military
that's
just a military that's discretionary
spending just say overall
anyway the point is there it is right
there social security unemployment labor
medicare health medicare and health
total mandatory spending that we have
yet but military's going to be different
than that
here's the point the point is if we keep
going the way we are and nobody
questions it we're just going to keep
coming up with new taxes
okay constantly coming up with new taxes
and eventually
here's another interesting fact for you
here's another interesting fact for you
which president increased the national
debt the most by percentage-wise
i'm going to guess lincoln he's
responsible for all of this give me a
lincoln but in this part it's an ftr
yeah it's 1075 which by the way was in
1930
you know when he was the new deal you
know who's the second
you should be able to guess it it's
1916. who was the guy with the 16th
amendment 1913 who's the 16th amendment
woodrow what was the draw he's second
place okay he's second place who do you
think's dollar amount the most
obama 8.8 trillion dollars you know
who's second place
trump it's very interesting when you
look at the numbers and see what's going
on
but percentage-wise fdr and woodrow
wilson changed
the entire tax system in america and
very few of us sit there and study about
it i don't know i just think there's an
opportunity for us to learn more yeah so
when it comes down to tax time and
voting we're going to vote in a
different way
this segment has been sponsored by turbo
tax if you have not done your taxes yet
turbo tax by the way
turbo tax is very thankful for even
saying their name right yes because yeah
some people actually think it is turbo
tax
it's actually not sponsored by turbo tax
it's sponsored by
um dvd tax no no what's the green
company the green lights
h r blocks yeah no neither one of them
okay so we're not the only thing that
i'm still thinking about and during that
whole segment what's that that china's
one base is in japan
they got that jabuti yeah there you go
and we should send adam to go do a
segment on
man on the streets in djibouti i'll go
yeah i'm looking to do some are you up
for it can you say you're upward if we
send you there or not
if i'm going to djibouti you may not be
getting something
all right so okay let's go and see what
story we want to go with
um adam for whatever reason wants
the florida story okay which is i think
you want that story do i want the story
i asked you
what story do you want to cover and what
did he say i said florida did he also
said pharma but then he said florida
here's what he said he says honestly i
haven't really looked at the notes but
yeah whatever just pick us up i'm just
excited
i'm fired up i had my coffee today go
all right so uh kai you got to remind me
about the super chat times 10 to see how
that's going to be yeah do you want to
repeat that one more time because i
i was fine i don't understand that body
who does a super chat
and we like it at the end we're going to
pay you back 10 times of what you gave
us
okay so if you did a ten dollar super
chat we're gonna get like four instances
right now yeah
john brothers uh raise taxes on soyboy
mafia ten bucks i actually think you
know what screw it john you got ten
times that so
johnny's getting a hundred bucks make a
note
john brothers just got a hundred bucks
we're paying ten bucks raise taxes on
soybean mafia
john text us your phone number to three
one zero uh three four zero one one
three two we may just even call you
three one zero three hang on one second
three one zero three four zero one one
three two
text us kai check the number say i'm
john brothers with your number
we may drop you i want to understand
what just happened john johnny
here he gave 10 bucks he said comments
is on soleboy
yeah we like the comment for no reason
i'm giving him back 10 times
for what he gave us which is what ten
times ten bucks is a hundred bucks he's
getting he seems like a little bit
with a hundred bucks look at that well
we had a funny comment about the soybean
mafia to tax that
you're offended by i'm deeply offended
adam will take sixty percent of that
exactly tax man you think you got jokes
we're gonna we're gonna tax that out
he's gonna do it at ninety four percent
fdr he'll get six sixty cents yeah
that's what he's getting
anyways all right john send us a text
we'll send you that money uh okay so
let's go to florida where we have with
florida paige what
page six okay so did that kind of make
sense to you what we're doing
we're 10 we're 10x whatever you give and
we have to like it we're going to be
encouraging
so you got to keep track of the comments
because if you don't then i'm not going
to be able to track any of this stuff
just make sure you're tracking
so people uh okay south florida let's
see what happened florida florida law
seeks to reign in
large social media companies this is an
ap story
standing at a lectern with a signed
reading stop
big tech censorship republican florida
governor desantis signed a bill on
monday that seeks to punish social media
platforms
that remove conservative ideas from
their sites the new law
will enable state to find large social
media companies
a quarter of a million dollars a day a
day if they remove an account of a
statewide political candidate and
25 000 a day if they remove an account
of someone running for a local office
desantis pointed out
in particular to them president donald
trump being banned by twitter while
still allowing
iranian supreme leader ayatollah
khamenei to maintain an account
when you de-platform the president
united states but you let ayatollah
khamenei
talk about killing jews that is wrong
desantis says
this bill targets social media platforms
that have more than 100 million monthly
users which include online giants as
twitter facebook but lawmakers carved
out an exception for disney and their
apps by including
that theme park owners wouldn't be
subject to that of course because
disney is in florida the santas has to
take care of us so anyway so what do you
think about this
i'm gonna go through this okay here's my
initial thought and i'm the only
non-resident
of florida here so let me say this from
an outsider's perspective
and here's the thing um there's one
thing i think of desantis
is starting his campaign for president i
mean i don't know how much meat this is
gonna have but he wants to be the guy
out on the fourth there's no republican
out there that's
that you could think could possibly run
in three and a half years not one not
trump
i mean he's laying so low you don't even
know what he's doing right now i mean he
made big news the other day because he
hit a golf ball into the water on his
golf course that was news the other day
so i think desantis is running for
president i don't know how much meat
this is going to have
i don't believe that zuckerberg and
dorsey and anybody is actually shaking
over this
they're not worried about this one bit i
think it's on the surface it looks good
it sounds good
i think there's a lot of vagueness in
here uh ambiguity in here that you
really don't understand
how they're gonna enforce it yeah but it
looked good at the press conference and
it is especially effective
if you're running for president in 2024
which this gentleman will be doing
so you think he's going 20 25. you're
going to see huge announcements out of
florida
every two months santos is going to run
i mean he looks like a leader when he
does this and he's laying the groundwork
of what his platform's going to be
i think he's obviously eyeing the uh the
presidency but it's a little too early
to tell we got to get through the
midterms i mean we just got i mean biden
just got elected what uh six months ago
honeymoon's over
honeymoon's over we're breaking up find
someone to beat him yeah
i i would happen to agree with that but
i think i've been pretty clear about the
about big tech where even when uh major
williams was here i said look
uh trump's been banned from a lot of
these platforms twitter facebook youtube
everything
uh instagram he hasn't made an instagram
post since the insurrection
i think big tech is a little getting a
little too
big for their britches to put it apropos
speech
and i think this is something that needs
to be said
mark zuckerberg's and facebook's
approval ratings are in the 20 30
percent trump's at 40
and i think this is something that's
good for sound bites like you said i
don't know how they're going to enforce
this
who's going to enforce 250 000 a day how
is that actually going to take place
send them an invoice see if they pay
yeah what's going to happen how are they
going to actually
police this thing yeah how do they
police that i don't know all i know is i
love the idea
you do and all i know is many of the
federal ideas start at the state level
which means this may be an idea being
started not at the state level
when the next republican president gets
elected he's going to say we're making
this federal and i'm boom yeah then the
federal is going to get involved and
saying wait a minute you just said
you're a social media company but now
you want to ban people
if you want to ban political people you
have to get approval by us because now
you're involved with the government and
here's what we're going to be doing
quarter million dollars a day i can see
this smart uh-huh
when you explain it like by the way
quarter million a day right it's not
quarter million
a month that's three million a year
quarter million a day which is seven and
a half million dollars
a month which is 90 million a year
that's real money
just so everybody knows that is real
money when did trump get banned kai can
you tell me when trump got banned the
day after the insurrection yeah the 23rd
or something the 2030 got banned okay
how many days since the 23rd
do the match five months okay five
months what's five times uh it's been
four months or five
20 days something like that 120 days 120
days some 75 000
is what what's 120 days it's going to be
what 30 million dollars
okay 120 times 30 uh 120
times a quarter million
that's real money 30 million dollars so
twitter would be famous 30 million
dollar fine right now okay i think they
look at that as the cost of doing
business
i don't think so i think 30 million is a
real number you don't think so i don't
ultimately because if they can keep on
doing what they're doing and not change
i think they pay 90 million a year to do
that
i do no i disagree with you i think when
you start when you start paying fines of
30 million
90 million whatever the numbers are
that's going to get someone's attention
i think look big tech
and their overlordness is definitely
becoming a problem and
if i'm a conservative and i'm seeing
conservative voices being taken down
i'm rallying around this idea right here
so big tech has been censoring
conservative voices
i think something that they did well was
disclaimers fact checks this has turned
out not to be true
i think that's all well and fair
especially when you're full-on
lying or quote-unquote the big lie but
to full-on
censor somebody and say uh-uh the
president can't be on this
this voice can't be on this at the end
of the day this is america we do believe
in the first amendment freedom of speech
you can't just completely censor what
i'm saying so what you're saying is you
like what he's doing he's making noise
and he's bringing attention to it
because it's got a lot of people
concerned by the way we have another
person here hodges wife that just gave
10 bucks i just like what she
quoted foreign aid is taking money from
the poor people of a rich country
and giving it to the rich people of a
poor country let me read that one more
time that's a ron paul quote
foreign aid is taking money from the
poor people of a rich country
and giving it to the rich people of a
poor country
she gets 10 times 10 bucks hodge's wife
sent us a text
three one zero three four zero one one
three two you're getting a hundred
dollars i just knife
i like how just is hodge getting any of
that much yeah haji's wife haji's i
don't know how to pronounce it
i hope you're listening by the way steve
levitz uh just gave a hundred bucks he
wants to talk with israeli army he was
in it for eight years
text us we may just give you a call yeah
i think it's all gonna come crumbling
down for these uh
social media companies i really do
because now you're even seeing this and
there might be a segment later in the
show sasha barack cohen is there a
bigger
liberal you know person that's more you
know socially
left than anybody else criticizing jack
dorsey for allowing the hate speech on
israel
they're getting high on their own supply
it's like a drug dealer that gets
addicted to coke
they're gonna make they're gonna be so
arrogant so cocky so out of control
now not much can happen until the
republicans get at least
one part of the government if they take
over the house in a year and a half i
believe
behind closed doors they are aligning
themselves to go
right after public enemy number one is
the big tech companies i mean you hear
about it right now i actually agree with
you and a lot more people are going on
both sides by the way yeah and
something has to be done eventually and
i think this is a brilliant move by
desantis because it shows strength it
shows four-sidedness it shows leadership
and he can fall back on it when he's
running for president yeah and he might
even be able to push this through in
florida because he gets his way here
good point yeah that's it
he's about to drop it i was going to say
that he has a mate
are you checking texts when he says have
they responded already okay so i want to
just call john real quick go ahead
i mean you may want to give me the the
valuetainment phone as well so i can do
facetime if we can get that
and if the phone line is working i'm
going to cut adam off about seven more
times but go ahead
no it's hard to freaking argue with when
desantis says when you deplot from the
president united states but you let the
ayatollah khomeini
talk about killing jews that is wrong
who the [ __ ] is going to argue who's
going to argue with them
and they should put the pressure on but
here's the point answer the question no
kidding
me dorsey answer the question exactly
they all haul their asses in front of
congress again
let me ask you a question how much does
sasha cohen
hate trump is it fair to say he cannot
stand trump
very fair is that a fair statement right
is it fair to say that he can't stand
giuliani with what he did and
julian is it fair to say that he likes
to go out there and mess with republican
politicians
is that a fair assessment for how many
years and and democrats he's messed with
bernie i would say
90 percent as republicans 10 percent is
democrat okay fair enough
you know who we just went after a couple
days ago who do you think just went
after
he went after jack dorsey can you pull
up the story with him because i don't
have it in front of me kyle if you can
pull it up just pull up any story
type in sasha cohen let's not disrespect
sasha cohen h-e-n and dorsey just put in
uh
jack dorsey doris there you go jersey
he's gonna be fine okay all right let's
go to fox news new york plus go to
go to a new york post story go to a new
york post story so if you can make it
bigger so the guys can listen do me a
favor flip the screen let's go on that
real quick
sasha baron cohen blast twitter c over
social media anti-semitism
if you're giving me the phone uh okay
got it sasha baron cohen blast twitter c
over social media anti-semitism keep
going up
okay keep going up uh uh uh keep going
up keep going up
the surge in anti-semitism on the
streets is fueled by anti-semitism on
social media the borant
actor posted on twitter on saturday
tagging both the platform and ceo jack
dorsey
why do you allow hashtag hitler was
right question he wrote
those who celebrate the holocaust aim to
perpetuate another stop hate for profit
baron cohen was apparently reacting to
an anti-defamation league report
released saturday that said more than 17
000 tweets use variations of the phrase
hitler was right between may 7th and may
14 in seven days
that's 7 000 tweets and sasha baron
cohen is the same guy that doesn't like
anything about trump that goes after
dorsey so it's no longer becoming
a republican thing people are starting
to realize the power
of dorsey and how one-sided they are and
that's his homeland
israel i mean you could see how
passionate is about this how do you not
have an
algorithm that weeds out references to
hitler being a positive thing
how is that not in place you know they
have an explanation
that they have to make they have to talk
about where's dorsey he hasn't responded
to this at all how can he not say i
cannot believe that this has happened
under my watch we got to get this thing
fixed
nothing you know and you got a few likes
for some from
other celebrity trump basher i think
mark ruffalo you know there's a few
other celebrities
on board as well but there's another one
it's reprehensible it's unbelievable
actually this is a perfect example of
why you can't just be
uniformly left or right you kind of have
to just use your
actual mind and when you see something
wrong even if you're not a big
fan of trump or giuliani or whatever the
hell it is when you see something wrong
like this you have to call it out
like what jack dorsey is allowing that's
great by the way here's the thing
let me tell you what i like i like the
fact what just happened right now with
sasha coming to me is the following
sasha cohen officially to me became a
true believer that he
really doesn't sincerely like the
policies on the right republican
policies which is fine
but he has policies that he also
believes in that he wants to impose and
is not afraid to ruffle the feathers
of the organization that's helping his
political party
moving agendas sasha cohen to me falls
in the category of a
jon stewart he falls in the category of
bill maher to me he falls in the
category of somebody tucker carlson
is not liked by republicans all the time
just so you know there's a lot of
republicans
that hate tucker but they like hannity
they cannot stand tucker so
you're seeing a lot of this taking place
and i think that's exactly what we need
today yeah and he addressed something
that isn't just politically
incorrect right that he was offended by
i mean there are jews being attacked
right now
in los angeles in new york all over the
country and this is fueling it
he has a legitimate beef dorsey has to
say something he literally does i mean
on the heels of what was going on with
israel and hamas you know for two and a
half weeks
is unbelievable and you can just feel
the passion in that tweet as well he's
not done i'm sure he's you know what
else does he have to do he's retired
borat he's not gonna be bored anymore he
said that at the golden globes this year
so
you know maybe he's gonna be a political
activist by the way the super chat's
going crazy
we're trying to catch up with you here
on what's going on and uh you guys keep
bringing it coming
uh uh uh there's yara g rest in peace to
my father rafael guerre 10 6 43 to 5
to 5 23 21 we will miss you and your
carefree spirit don't cry when i die
celebrate my life and party this is yara
g gave 10 bucks guess what you are i'm
going to give you 20 times i'll give
them 200 bucks make a note
and text it to us what a heartfelt thing
right politician
no man i just i'm not running for
nothing i'm just running for a youtube
channel you're right now i'm running a
business but you're not running for
collection i want to i want to call a
couple of these guys one of the guys who
was in the israeli army if we can get a
hold of him that would be great kai if
you can give me his number if he texts
us already
uh and i i wouldn't mind having somebody
who is
got the argument of israel to go up
against the argument of palestine
there's a couple people that commented
here about that as well
hank tied we are seeing your comments
we'll get to here in a minute as well
as we're going through so let's continue
let's continue because uh we have
some more topics to go through okay next
how about we talk about uh you said tom
you wanna
switch stories i said the foundation
let's go to page nine let's go to page
nine
fouchy bombshell not convinced kova 19
developed naturally outside wuhan lab
the hill story
anthony fauci the director of nih a
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
and president biden's chief medical
advisor supporting open investigation of
the coronavirus origin says earlier
this month he is not convinced or
developed naturally when asked about
whether the virus originally natural
naturally fauci said that he wants to
look closer to the matter according to
fox news
i'm not convinced about it i think we
should continue to invest again that
what happened in china
until we continue to find out to the
best of our abilities what happened that
she said speaking of poli
politifact katie sanders at an event
certainly the people who investigated it
said it was likely the emergence from an
animal reservoir then then
uh that then infected individuals but it
could have been something else and we
need to find that out so you know
that's the reason why i said i'm
perfectly in favor of the investigation
that looks into the origins of the virus
he continued the white house has not
prepared
evidence to refute the lab leak theory
with press secretary jim paske saying
the biden administration is concerned
that the chinese government was not
transparent from the beginning
really thoughts you know um dr fauci i'm
going to say his name right
okay he loves himself some fauci doesn't
he i mean he
loves being on the news he loves himself
some fauci
um he loves being on television he loves
being in the news he loves doing press
conferences so i've got a suggestion for
dr fauci
go on shark tank launch the fouchy
flip-flops
right a little pair of shoes summer's
coming up beach it'd be perfect he could
make millions on it
here's here's my and by the way kai
check your email i sent you a little
something that maybe we can pull up here
in just a second
you know pat fauci adam you guys know
people like this right
they're overpaid and they know it right
i don't know if there's some sort of
phrase for this but people that know
they're not worth the money they're
being paid
there are people like that they're c c
suites you know people that have
you know somehow gotten to high-ranking
jobs they know they're really not quite
good enough for not qualified enough for
and they're making big bucks so they
have to seem like they're
they're worth it justifying it every
single day that's how i look at fauci
he's the highest paid government
employee numero uno
no one makes more money than him he's
the highest paid he goes out that he's
insecure
i can read this guy like a book he knows
he's not as smart as everybody
is claiming he is and acting like he is
by the way when's the last time he
treated a patient
if you're going to be the number one
doctor in the country get the
stethoscope out
i want to see you in a lab coat get
under a microscope once in a while
be a freaking doctor okay not a by the
way
kai did you find this okay he's going to
pull something up here i have a new role
for
you for dr fauci so when we're ready for
that kai i'll announce what i think
fauci should focus on going forward okay
adam what are your thoughts
i think when tom hears the name fauci
triggers go off he's just
and uh alone i don't think he's alone
i don't think he's alone on the left or
the right okay a lot of people feel like
let me say something i am not pro-fauchy
but i am certainly not
anti-fouchy i think he's had a tough
freaking job i think when this thing
manifested in china there was nothing
anything we've seen like this in a
hundred years
and he was maybe a little over his head
but i think genuinely he tried to do his
best job
when he said back in march we don't
necessarily need masks
he came back and he flip-flopped on that
and that's been held against him for
a year now turns out maybe we didn't
need some freaking mess
and he had to and he didn't we did okay
and he had to reverse on that
however the bigger story here is this
continue
to investigate china this isn't about
fauci this is about
china at this point whether china
whether he's overpaid or whether he's
coming out with a new line of flip-flops
is freaking irrelevant what's important
here is investigating china you did an
interview with a lady
and who came out and basically came out
and said
i was a scientist working in a lab in
wuhan
and i can tell you conclusively this was
invented in a lab in china and then what
happened to that interview pat
yeah that's what's crazy when i did the
interview with the lady what was her
name by the way she was just on
tucker a couple days ago she was all
over the news she came out and she
talked about kyle you're looking up her
name or no
she was all over the news they were
talking about she says this is
remember this of course so we
interviewed her and the interview in two
days got half a million
views then they took it down yeah and we
didn't understand why they took it down
they also took down a judy mike of its
interview
the big tech overlords judy used to work
with fauci
in the 80s during the aids pandemic that
was taking place so so the biggest
challenge i have with fauci is the
following
find that you're saying now yes we need
to look into it
but why is the fact that so many other
people said we need to look into it why
were they censored
exactly that's the hypothetical to me so
so you
how many billions of views was taken
down just because people questioned
the source of where it came from how
many actually curious still don't think
about that
it got to a point that you didn't even
want to post videos because they were
striking
they were putting strikes on it they
were taking it down so there's a part of
it that a lot of audiences
and by the way we look at our content on
valuetainment we used to get a lot more
recommendation than we do our views used
to be
75 by recommended from another video
that recommended this is pretty much
flatlined for us we don't get
recommended anymore like we used to
by taylor's list on valuetainment we
used to be recommended on
75 of our views 50 to 75 percent of our
viewers were recommended we don't have
that number anymore why i don't know i'm
not speculating
yeah and by the way i'm not even going
to the point of shadow banning or
whatever people want to say if you do
want to do that go ahead and do that hey
audience you know what i tell about the
audience
get even more on notification share the
content even more that's on you if you
really want to see the stuff being
shared
share it even more be part of a group
that we need to get this message out
there more i don't think enough people
people are sitting there kind of saying
this content makes sense rather than
saying this makes sense let me share
with 10 people
we need to get the ability to share even
more people need to be willing to share
the content more
but that took place to us last year i
kind of sat there and i'm like
really just because somebody said that
this could have been from the inside in
china so
the silencing part concerns me i applaud
fauci
for saying we ought to look into this
good for you but he should have said
that
seven months and he shouldn't have not
right now at on the early exactly
because when rand paul just a couple
months ago asked him the question
he laughed at the idea he laughed at the
idea
and now you're changing your position
look john kerry years ago was supposed
to be the president
i don't know if you remember or not yeah
he was supposed to he was supposed to be
the president
until he got caught what flip-flopping
he was the ultimate flip-flopper okay
the guy went to i think he went to yale
i think he's one of those guys
that went to all the right schools he
was about to be the president he got a
lot of heat for what
one minute you're saying this one meant
you're saying that you're saying this to
the audience you're saying that to the
audience it should have been bush he
should have been the president
flip-flopper vouchers starting to
flip-flop a lot and people are getting
pissed off
make up your damn mind with everything
politicians
he just made the point found she's a
politician he's not a doctor
he's another member of the cabinet if
you ask me he is not a doctor
he is he is a doctor no he literally i
will give him that he's as much of a
doctor as doc severson was when he was
the leader of the tonight show band
no he is a doctor i will give him that
he went to medical school he is a doctor
okay but act like one okay be a doctor
have an opinion
like a doctor i disagree i disagree
wholeheartedly you want him to treat
patients
like he's like so i want him to
dermatologist down the street
treat a patient if you're going to be
the top doctor i have high expectations
for you a little bit more than just
going which way the wind blows which is
what he does
look he's a cabinet member the guy's
been the guy
again i'm not pro-fauchy but i'm not
anti-fauci like you
the guy's been put in a tough position
this virus came out of china
he's he's been in the how long has he
been there through 40 years almost
which means it's time to go okay granted
i'm just saying he's been through
republican presidencies democratic
presidencies he's been around the block
he knows more than most so so for
someone who's like rand paul who's a
freaking
eye doctor to sit there and try to
battle fauci yeah but timeout
i think rand paul's been wrong more than
one way he's still a doctor rand paul
eye doctor
it's not about a doctor of infectious
diseases versus an eye doctor
i take fouchy's opinion over iran but
also okay so fine but here's here's a
question here's a question for you
it's not about whether rand paul is
right or wrong
it's about the fact that what the hell
is wrong with questioning
anything i'm cool with that no it's not
then if you are cool with that rand paul
is not saying he's right
no he is rand paul is asking and
questioning which is totally fine
which you which you as a person who is
responsible for the world
relying on your opinion the world was
affected by a virus that came out of
china do you not think we need to go
figure out what the hell happened in
china do you not think we need to go
what the hell happened rather than
saying it's probably not them what do
you mean it's probably not them by the
way here's a quick here's another
question for you
how much money is the right amount of
money to spend to find out if they
actually did this intentionally how much
whatever it takes infinite amount that's
the point there
why why is it so important because it
could happen again because if it is
true if it is true you know what this is
called if this
is true you know what this is called
this is not a j this is
how many people got killed because of
covet what's the latest number because
of kovalev millions
what is the number total death of i'm
guessing
total numbers from kobe cove total death
3 million that's my guess that what's
the total number
uh uh not just u.s worldwide 2.6 million
2.6 yeah okay do you realize
uh a holocaust how many people six
million okay
i was just jews that's the number in
total it was 10 million
20 million so you've heard six million
to 20 million numbers okay armenian
genocide
million people one and a half million
plus another half a million greeks plus
another quarter million assyrians right
cambodia do you want me to keep going
you're going reparations is that where
you're going are you
kidding me of course are you kidding me
if you
did this you need to be held at the
highest are you
so here's what to me everybody needs to
put their money up and say what the hell
happened and they need to be held
accountable this is not
people don't by the way this wasn't even
that deadly
this was a one percent virus
if this was a five percent do you know
what that is
if this was if this this thing's are not
score was even higher
than what it is you know what this could
have looked like twenty fifty million
whatever the arnott score was higher
okay which is the the share a bit
the the fact that it spreads faster if
it was higher
and more deadly dude what are you
talking about like a couple of us
wouldn't be sitting here right now
do you realize like like think about
you're not here right now i'm not here
right now
he's not here right now he's not here
right now a couple of us wouldn't be
sitting here right now
so the point is rather than saying it's
trump's fault this sir stop
where did it come from let's go to it i
don't care if it costs money
let's find out rather than sitting on
the sidelines and saying
oh let's get biden elected oh let's get
trump elected forget about all this
politics
what the hell happened let's get to the
bottom of this all this political games
they're playing
is getting old so the fact that fouch is
finally saying
we have to find out great put a budget
behind it
what's the budget let's go if china
wants to play ball
and they did this rather than sitting
there saying what are we going to do
with the what do you call it the you
know we have a lot of import that's
coming from that we have 80
of pharmaceuticals that's coming from we
have 70 of the chips that are coming
from there
really that's what so you're going to
keep empowering these guys over and over
if this is true this is reparations at
the highest level
this is i did it to you and i can get
away with it and you can't do nothing
about it yeah and they're working on the
next one
it's an act of war really i mean i mean
they're actually going to allow people
in the country and to investigate what
point is yes we should investigate of
course we should of course we should put
a ridiculous budget behind it
not only the united states the entire
world should do this but the question is
is china going to allow people to
actually go into the lab
but let's just say they don't question
people okay fine let's say they don't
let's say let's say they don't tax that
ass what i'm saying to you
say they don't yeah okay like you know
how people say you know how
there's cops will go to a house and they
say i know this guy's a murderer well
you can't go on unless you have a what
a warrant a warrant okay what if they
still don't let you in what do you got
to do you got to knock down that damn
door and what if you can't do that with
china what do you got to do well you're
not going to knock down china's door
because what is our form of knocking
down the door
spy what is it people are doing we're
going to have to put uh
taxes on that ass and sanctions all that
of course you have
the world has to do this it can't just
be the united states alone this has to
be a global coalition to say
i'm sorry ah buddy we gotta come in that
door india is willing to do it
u.s is willing to do it australia is
willing to do it canada is willing to do
it the eu's willing to stop
together that's the point so if that's
where we're going
and what i'm saying to you it's if
fauci's gotten to this point
this is great news i like the fact that
vouch has gotten to this point and i
like the fact that
the the spanish what's her name spas
pasque sasaki
uh whatever her name is saki uh says
not transparent from the beginning
the the the by the administration is
concerned that the chinese government
was not transparent from the beginning
you know what i'm sensing here let me
tell you what i'm sensing here right now
one the one one of the things america
desperately needs right now
desperately needs right now is the
following you know what 911 did
democrats went and helped chase down
republican kids
republicans went out and said hey mary
what's going on i can't find my husband
i'll help you let's go
people forgot about people people just
said what do you believe red white and
blue
great let's go today in the world 2.6
million people died you know what we
bleed all of us
red it's not red white and blue right
now let's figure out who the hell was
behind us yeah how this took place
yeah so and guess what anybody including
that virologist that went and said this
was a man-made guess what
let's listen to them what's the
statement in america when somebody gets
charged with a crime what is it called
innocent to what proven guilty hey you
know what let's hear what you got to say
tell us you know and now people are
basically saying what she said wasn't
crazy i mean you know maybe you put that
video back up on youtube here's the
other thing to follow and watch is
you're going to see the mainstream media
you know echoing these same statements
that maybe it was coming out of china
and they're already starting to do it
cnn washington post new york times npr
they're all kind of doing the same thing
when they mocked it and ridiculed it
you know a year ago now they're saying
hey maybe now here's my problem with
fouch you know i'm not a big fan right i
think he's the mascot of the coronavirus
that's literally what i think he is but
here's my problem with him
people take their marching orders and
their cues from him um when he comes out
with two masks
and he's always got a fearful message
that's what he's always throwing out
there it's gloom and doom it's never
positive
you still see people driving around with
masks while they're driving their car
you see people walking outside no one
around them they have their masks on
healthy looking people i saw chris paul
yesterday wearing a mask when coach
williams was talking to him
two days ago and he's at the asylum like
dude what are you doing wearing a mask
when he's about to go in
he's he's playing he puts his mask on to
sit on the bench are you like serious
post-game interviews there are masculine
sitting on each other sweating on each
other and that's my problem with fauci
because he just goes the way the wind
blows
but he's got a voice he's got a
megaphone and people fall for it
you talked about jon stewart jon stewart
has become famous for the last 10 years
for doing what
speaking out on behalf of both sides
first responders yeah from 9 118 that's
right
so i have an idea what's that i think
there needs to be a global
uh public hearing a coalition a a
full-on testimonial testifying in front
of a
world response global pandemic supreme
court type of thing
and get out there and have people
testify as to what happened globally
uh what's the what isn't there a global
uh what's a
the world court what's it called anyone
uh by
uh by uh there's a name for it yeah
the global coalition uh court whatever
the hell
something whatever it is yeah keep going
people need to get out there and testify
just like that jon stewart does and he's
always in front of uh
congress testifying on behalf of 911
there needs to be
a unilateral triglyceride court whatever
the hell the word is
uh and the this needs to be out there
here's the question
what percentage of this do you think was
a percentage the odds
that it was man-made versus a bat and
wuhan
i'll say 80 or higher i mean 80 man-made
yes i think china's back they're
laughing at us i'm thinking about the
next one that they can unleash
pat so if i do the call i have to keep
the phone here right is that what you're
telling me
or no it's going to be on there uh i'm
gonna say ten percent ten percent ten
percent that it was
but let me tell you what i mean by ten
percent uh uh i'm i'm extremely
skeptical
so i'm i'm but i'm not a i'm i'm
skeptical but i'm also
not convinced it was a hundred percent
you know man-made i'm saying 10
but to me 10 is still a high number yes
i'm not one in 10 chance that this was
man-made
why i uh i think honestly
uh trump was negotiating so
hardcore with them that they just said
watch what we're going to do to you
i think this was a vendetta china had
against trump and
uh if if that is uh if that if that's my
10 percent is that though that's my 10
percent
my 10 percent is trump was getting in
the way because all the other
politicians had made it easy for china
to compete at the highest level and
trump made it
very difficult so they said we gotta get
we gotta get rid of this guy so let's
throw a thorn in there and here
you know you're ten percent kai what are
you percentage was man-made go ahead
um probably like five five percent
you guys percentage man-made
i would say five-two oh my god okay i'm
going to rational go ahead sam what do
you got
i'm going gonna rationalize my 80 no i
said it's at least fifty percent fifty
percent
why wouldn't we ask the audience guys
percentage that you think it was
man-made tom's at eighty percent
pat's at ten percent i'm right around
five ten percent as well
i think eighty percent of the greatest
amount of people have done let me ask
you a question wouldn't you be more five
or ten percent if
the timeline was flip-flopped now
government
fauci media is all saying it's a very
good chance
they weren't saying that at the
beginning and then a year and a half
later they're saying no it came from a
bat crazy aggressive tom but that's all
good
that's your but it's your number i said
five to ten percent i said it that's
where i'm at let's get our audience in
there
yeah if you're watching this a lot of
people are saying fifty percent yuri
says fifty percent
kate lemon says a hundred percent 100
percent ryan says
20 angry happy says 90 percent uh
uh joshua tomer says 69 he feels like i
think he's a little single right he's
watching yeah he's
uh elon musk yeah so we got a bunch of
by the way a lot of people are saying on
the
like on the high end i haven't seen
anybody at five percent or ten percent
everybody's on a hand well
it is what it is um that's 69 is
trending i think that's gonna be the
number problem i'm serious a lot of
people are putting 69
it seems like he started trent okay so
by the way anas a couple people
commented on us i see you i just want
you to know anas i see you when it comes
down to israel and palestine what i'd
like to do
is to get what i'm trying to do is to
get a few people from both sides to get
on and talk about the topic because i
want to hear
somebody from the israel side i want to
hear somebody from palestine's side
maybe even two and two
to put them on to talk about let me call
somebody here right now let me call
somebody here right now so we had
do i leave it in does it have to be in
yeah do you have to leave it
i don't think it's gonna work because if
i keep it from all the way there to make
it
just keep it close to the mic i have to
keep it in and close to the mic no no
then you have no i'm going to do it this
way yeah let me see this here hang on
we're going to call somebody
who was a uh israeli uh soldier for
eight years so let's hear and then anas
ana still hasn't texted his number on us
can you text me your number
can you text me your number let me see
here
all right so steve levitz let's see
hello is this steve yes steve how are
you
mr patrick how are you my friend i am
doing very good so steve so you said you
were in the israel army for eight years
yeah i'm the one that sent you the the
toys for your family every christmas oh
man you're so amazing i appreciate that
brother thank you so much for doing that
the kids appreciate it as well
i appreciate it thank you so so tell us
what do you think about what's going on
with israel and palestine you were in
the israeli army for eight years
obviously this is a very very
uh heated debate on debate on both sides
folks from palestine have strong
opinions folks from israel have strong
opinions what are your thoughts about
what happened there
okay my thought is the fact you know i'm
sorry my english is not the best but
i've been there for
i lived there for 35 years now i live in
orlando
but i was there for eight years people
doesn't understand i hate when people
say they see the news and they say oh
free palestine free israel people have
no clue what's going on
we're treating the arab better than
anyone else if hamas will literally
control
the gaza and they will take over
whatever the dream to take over israel
yeah the arab will suffer like nobody
ever understand that
people don't understand how we give we
give them water electric they work with
us i actually know their language i work
with them i have millions of afraid
arabs and they even understand that the
israeli arab especially
they understand what's going on if the
hamas will take over they are done
they treat them they beat them in the
street they do whatever they want you
cannot go without you know
the cover on the head they will beat you
you cannot it's like
they're going to make it like iran which
you know better than anyone
people don't understand how moral i
never hit no arabs for no reason i never
shot no one for no reason people doesn't
understand what's going on there they're
all about blood
they're going behind school the shooting
so we can shoot the kids and they can
chew it in cnn
it's unbelievable what's going on
unbelievable i'm like i'm in shock
people just
throwing memes and social media free
palestine they have no clue what's going
on
are you saying that the hamas believes
in sharia law
100 okay 100
continue did you have a follow-up i just
wanted to see if that's what he was
trying to say
and by the way can you unpack that
unpack that for
us and the listeners okay so
so for example if you go now to let's
say
gaza or jericho or whatever okay yeah
and uh
just for example you're gonna ask a
father with four kids yeah let's say you
have two boys and two girls
we ask them how many kids you have you
know what we say what
two he will never say they don't count
the girls
they treat them like garbage the
treatment just to clean the house to
have babies and that's it
they don't have a state they don't have
a ward they don't have nothing people
don't get it
they believe in sharia because also
that's how they take the taxes that's
how they take their money
and people that need i was in gaza just
gaza for one year and eight months
i was four months of them undercover
what i feel there is unbelievable they
hate they have the blood that they did
it i wish i wish i could just like
youtube my time on
the army which wasn't bad steve do you
mind do you mind if i three-way anasan
who is on the complete opposite side
because he's got some strong opinions
and see if the rest of us can just
listen to the two of you guys uh have a
discourse is that okay with you
okay honest i'm about to call you folks
hang tight i'm trying to get on us in
uh give me a second here anas thank you
for your patience let me see if i got
the number 1929
all right 231 6308 here we go
and who is that now exactly i don't know
who annas is
i don't know who hanas is uh anas has
got the complete opposite opinion
then when steve has anas can you hear us
yes
how are you doing today i'm doing
wonderful i appreciate you i'm on a
three-way you went hang tight for me did
you hear the comments steve made
yes okay so hang on before you bring in
steve anas give us your bio
wait let me bring steve because it
doesn't matter they got to know each
other anyway
so uh uh so at this point we know
steve's background is he was in the
israeli army atf so so
so steve can you take 30 seconds and
give us your background once again you
said eight years
in the israeli army tell us a little bit
more again
okay yeah i was eight years i joined
army when i was 18. in israel you have
to be
three years in the army but i signed
more than i become an officer for eight
years
i was almost two years in gaza and the
rest on ramallah
on the arab area i was a commander
450 soldiers and i can guarantee you
that we are the most moral army ever we
give them food
we give them everything we treat them
good they're working with us
and perfect on us can you give us your
back steve thank you for that honest
give us your background before you guys
can go into
i'm palestinian i was born in this
country i was raised in palestine for a
year
so unfortunately your guest i think he's
kind of misinformed
about a few things so number one so
number one
i'm gonna be respectful here because he
was respectful so i'm gonna be
respectful for example we treat our
daughters and sons the same way
my family have a lot of daughters in our
family and my uncle he says that he
likes his daughters more than his
sons so i think that he has to talk
about those things number one but number
two i want to
say something important patrick is that
as a palestinian as a muslim for
and foremost as a muslim i condemn
killing civilians
because in islam we're not allowed to
kill civilians it's in the sharia law if
one could read the shri allah it says in
islam they're not allowed to kill
civilians
no matter what and i want to tell this
young man here
this gentleman here because you know
he's a good man he's educated i hope
is that uh the palestinians they elected
hamas because those elections in
palestine there was no elections
recently because
israel and the american government and
the the federal party doesn't want to
allow for
elections and if we look at the last war
because we say that israel is the most
moral army in the world
how do you know how many kids died pat
now like i don't care if it's israeli
kid or palestinian kid
a lot of kids died you know how many
kids got trauma
and they say oh how much they put the
rockies that have stocks there can you
see the evidence please i've been asking
the israeli you know
media and army to show us the evidence
that if there's rockets in the buildings
show it but no they didn't show it they
just use the
the planes to punish the palestinians
for voting for hamas
because they can't get to hamas and
hamas they're fighting face to face if
israel wants to
really destroy hamas go into gaza go
into gaza and be madness
fight one-on-one uh anyway if you have
to stay on topic because i'm i'm
palestinian i want to give you our side
as a palestinian and as a muslim i'm
going to say i'm take i condemn the
armenian genocide what happened in 1915.
many armenians were taken in by
palestinian lebanese and syrian families
you took the armenians in and
and we have to be you know straight here
israel was built on palestine 531
villages
was destroyed 11 cities was destroyed
tiberius nazir and nazareth all these
cities are in
today israel were once part of palestine
palestinians were who
lived there and they were kicked out of
their lands and this whole conflict
has started when the israeli army quote
unquote the most small army in the world
stormed islam's third holy site can you
imagine if a muslim army stormed
the vatican or stormed orthodox
christian church how would the world
react
can you imagine how would the world
react the turkish army stormed the
orthodox or greek church
and they desecrated it so let's be uh
straight here let's be uh
balanced here now i'm going to say on
tape if i must kill civilians i condemn
that 100 percent
i condem killing civilians 100 percent
because the rockets that they have
because iran provides some weapons but
these rockets are not uh
what you might call it they're not
accurate and plus hamas warned them
twice you see if you keep touching and
evict palestinians from their houses
we're gonna respond and israel didn't
heed the warning and hamas responded
now me i'm not
there are many smart there are many
smart palestinians in this world
that are engineers lawyers filmmakers
all this stuff and they can't
go with the full potential because
israel is putting a blockade on gaza and
we're not allowed to have our own
businesses in our own state back
but let me ask a question if new york or
los angeles was under a blockade
because because the people chose donald
trump and russia and china put america
under blockade and they
counted the calories that came in this
country how would america react
if someone came to your house and said
this is my house
and it's my house and because god said
how would you react like this
you have the right america gave you the
second amendment right to defend
yourself
the palestinians are practicing the
rights that god gave them that allah
gave them the second amendment rights to
to defend their land
defend the west bank defend our holy
sites okay
and and it's clear let me be very clear
about something if anybody
in america attacks a jew for no reason
even if he's from my own people
even he's an arab or a muslim i will
beat the crap out of him and defend that
jews writes
because i'm i'm a muslim i gotta say
something i gotta say something we got
lucky here but
uh steve i'm gonna come to you in a
second folks if you're listening in we
are probably the luckiest people to have
gotten this to
because you're both sounding obviously
there's some emotion behind you but
you're both being reasonable and
respectful to one another
i appreciate that that's the
valuetainment type of style steve i want
to hear your response to what anas just
said
yeah yeah go ahead steve sorry okay
first of all
i think he's talking about misinform hey
i don't know where you from in palestine
which area are you called
west bank west bank okay yeah i think
there's many years but
when you say arab doesn't just for
example if israel were
very mean like everybody try to we can
operate
palestine in a second we're trying never
to shoot we're telling everybody where
the hamas
you know if i got forbid shooting let's
say i have 20 kids around me
and i will shoot your house you wouldn't
say oh there's kids
behind steve i'm not gonna shoot him you
will freaking shoot me as much as you
can to protect your kids
so when they're going to kindergarten
and everything and they're shooting us
don't think that we're gonna say oh wait
what are we gonna do there is kids
because that's what you guys want to
show and second of all
not nothing elected really i mean you
have to be very naive to think that
hamas being elected freely
nobody really asks palestine who to vote
you know it's everything
it's 99 vote for hamas because that's
how it's going to work
and fatah was supposed to come now to
election and that's why
whatever his name is
yeah because he wanted to he didn't want
to have election because he will be lose
100 percent he will lose that's why
we agree i agree with him that's what he
did that is a distraction like
a lot of politicians yes you know that's
[ __ ] patrick what's ironic tell me
that all the leaders the hamas the king
that's selling all the kids to die you
think i care about i don't care about
kids dying yeah
but you know where they are they're all
in vegas they're all in dubai they're
not even there they're just saying
go die for palestine go up on their bus
brother with all the respect the leaders
well listen gentlemen i appreciate you
for your time this was great here's what
we're doing
i have a youtube channel we talk about
issues all the time why don't you put
the link in the description
i think i could put it in the
description put it in the description
the audience if they wanted they can
follow here's what i'm going to be doing
for both of you guys gang if you watch
this and you enjoyed
stephen and us click that subscribe
button steve you gave us
99 bucks and 99 cents i'm giving you 10
times back you're getting a thousand
dollars for uh doing what you did and on
anas you gave 20 bucks
i'm giving you 10.10 10 times back to
that as well you guys were
classics appreciate you guys take care
guys bye bye bye bye
awesome well done how awesome amazing a
lot of awesome was a lot of passions
intelligence and great perspective folks
if you loved this smash the thumbs up on
that i thought that was class act and
give a uh stephen and us uh some love uh
on the commentary
we're probably gonna bring those guys
back the way they give us their update
we're probably gonna bring
bring them back okay any take away from
you i think that's what valuetainment's
all about two reasonable people
with polar opposite perspectives having
a conversation and you being the
moderator and us
all listening and hearing what the
perspectives were i got to give it up to
steve
and abbas what was his name anas anas
total respect and you have someone who's
palestinian
who had a perspective he said he's
american so maybe he didn't really spend
a lot of time
in gaza one year he said one year yeah
and you have somebody who's
spent thirty-five years in the military
i speak
the language i will say there is a big
difference between the west bank
yes near jerusalem versus gaza oh that's
the question
okay exactly and uh uh
uh gaza is a lot worse than the west
bank and i will say
on behalf of uh steve said this he said
we could annihilate the palestinians if
we wanted to in one second which is true
which is true i sent you something about
that i don't know if you know what uh
yeah
what uh my friend israel has the most
powerful army this tiny little country
the size of delaware has the most
powerful army
in the entire middle east more per
capita more powerful than iran
more powerful than saudi arabia they
could destroy palestine they
could but they don't on on the on the
flip side
they do have a moral obligation israel
being a
democracy people that believe they try
to be a shining light in the city of a
hill like much like america yeah
in the middle east they do have a moral
obligation
to humanize the people of gaza
steve steve said um that they do not
hold free and fair elections i agree
with that
i do agree that that uh especially in
the west bank
uh mahmoud abbas has been uh there for
15 years
he has not had to face a re-election
there's a lot of corruption going on
especially in gaza
a lot of corruption but israel being the
shining light in the middle east
should do their best to have moral
authority over it
here's where i come out with steve that
perspective was unbelievable somebody in
the stream is going to be back
unbelievable they're going to be bad you
know and
i'll say this you know i love all people
that are peace-loving right i think most
people are in that
camp i like palestinians i love israelis
the whole thing
the wild card here is hamas right and i
think if you listen to steve that's what
he's talking about this is a terrorist
faction
that that fights very very unfairly and
dirty and that's who you know is causing
most of the problem i
i think palestinians and israelis could
live
you know a little bit more peacefully
than people give them credit for but
when you have the wild card factor like
hamas
and that's where you hear the the
passion and it really coming in because
they when you see the stuff probably
that steve's seen
and he hasn't told us you know probably
yet a fraction of what he knows
but it's unbelievable when you get uh
the perspective from somebody on the
ground
awesome i agree by the way julie swenson
just said
uh this is fantastic wow how lucky for
us to hear this julie i agree with you
she gave five dollars we're gonna give
ten times back
which is fifty dollars to julian so far
how many people have we given them ten
times
six money we've given away a couple
thousand dollars so we're already
saving that money today on the pb
podcast if you post a super chat that we
comment on or we like
i'm going to give you 10 times back what
your super chat is you give 10 right
uh steve just gave a hundred we give him
10 times back a thousand dollars
what time do we or what uh when do we
send them the tax form for the 60
tax that they have to pay on that
that'll be coming up
out of respect he said uh we are peace
loving people
you know they said that uh according to
sharia law yeah there's a lot of
jews being attacked we saw it in new
york we started in l.a just because
they're jewish
and he said i would tell my brethren
what the hell you're doing i'll beat the
crap out of my own arab friends muslim
friends
okay that is the type of attitude we
need i totally like if i had jewish
friends that were going around and
beating the crap
out of whoever i would think what the
frick is a matter with you bro
get it together that's the type of
attitude you need to be talking to your
own people about
so respect to him about that i think you
can get them in studio well aren't they
both in florida one's in orlando
orlando i gotta tell you steve steve's a
long time steve's so good to me i mean
he's a christmas gift he's such a nice
guy man i mean it's like this guy
the the class is something else man
there's some valuetainers out there that
are
so respectful about what we do he's
definitely in that category okay let's
talk about navy okay navy says it's
charting a
new course after rash of problems this
is a very interesting story
because it's six because it also has to
do with china
and how china's navy is slowly becoming
very very strong so navy says
is charting a new course after russia
promised this is a fox news story
embarrassing photos of rusty ships
online
have underscored delays in maintaining
warships made worse by the pandemic the
navy's trouble have caused delays and
costs of billions of billions of dollars
they come as tensions are grown in south
china sea
russia's navy is emboldened iranian
speed boats are harassing vessels in a
persian gulf
the navy fleet currently falls shy of
300 ships despite a
stated goal of 355 ships the chinese
fleet now
outnumbers the u.s navy let me say that
one more time the chinese fleet
officially
outnumbers the us navy and the most
expensive ship
in the navy history meanwhile is the
newest aircraft carrier the uss gerald
ford
it has had problems with the system that
launches jets and the elevators that
moves weapons amongst other things it
was supposed to cost 10 and a half
billion dollars but the price tag
has risen to 13.3 billion dollars and
four weapon elevators are still not
finished and the reliability of key
systems is low says republican senator
jim
uh chairman and ranking member of the
armed service committee what do you
think about
this with china i'd say on the surface
this is very embarrassing yeah
this isn't like a a a headline where
you're like
uh yeah this is great congratulations
this is actually embarrassing
but this will go back to your initial
point of maybe it's time to
update the type of warfare that we're
investing in right you talked about that
we have 800 military
military bases around the world china
has one in my favorite city in the world
that booty djibouti my bad
and the maybe just maybe it's time for
us to take a
step back and realize all right maybe we
don't need all this maybe we need to
reinvest and allocate that money into
something a little more modern
rather than your typical traditional
assets so maybe this is a pause and
reset
for the us navy just maybe you know the
one thing that steps out for me
that scares me a little bit you know
usually i want to get too caught up
because
you know they have more they have a
billion people they're going to have
more military members than we do just
sheer numbers but
is it the sin whatever is going on off
the coast of japan
and in that area where there's a very
very volatile area with the islands that
they're going to be
eventually tussling over that's south
china yeah everybody has to take that
very very seriously so if you're talking
about the chinese navy
i immediately go to that and there's a
legitimate threat there so
you know is it going to be a submarine
battle is it going to be two warships
going at it probably not
you know the war will be fought
differently but that's a that's an area
that kind of scares me so if you're
talking about the navy
and their dominance and the importance
that china's putting into it i think of
that region because we can't agree on
anything we just fight amongst ourselves
in this country
china knows exactly who their enemy is
every single day
i agree as being being an army guy do
you have any thoughts on the navy or
i think i think i look at china as being
so strategic
that i ask myself why why what is china
doing investing in the navy
like why are they having so many fleets
what what for
is it because you know uh uh the
surrounding nations is it because of
in case something's happens at suez
canal is it because
u.s has ships out there and they're not
comfortable about it is it
what's their motive why ship so so
because you know when you when you're
say you're playing a video game and so
one guy and you know how you
go out there and you're playing one of
those race games right and it says
you have this much money do you want to
invest it into a nicer car into turbo
into
a better suspension into better tires
and to better whatever right so you buy
turbo and all of a sudden a guy comes in
who's a 10-time champion whatever and he
buys
wheels you're like why wheels well he's
buying wheels for a reason because
wheels
if you get better let's just say tires
it's going to stick better so you're
gonna have better handling while you may
have turbo and you may crash but i'm
gonna have better
in the turns so there's a reason why
he's picking so i'm
i'm trying to see why is china investing
so much money in their navy
if they're doing it there's got to be a
reason they're they're very methodical
in what they do they don't just invest
into anything
look at the military base they have one
foreign military base around the world
what for they're sitting there saying we
can use that money for military base
better by doing it in a different way so
if they're putting it into navy and u.s
is sitting there falling behind china
there's got to be something happening
let me ask you a question yeah
obviously we talk about china a lot on
the show i mean this is something we
talk about and everything that's going
on
and hey you better watch out hey you
better watch out china's doing this
china's beating us in this better watch
out freaking china in your opinion
what's a china's achilles heel at this
point what are they not seeing what are
they slipping on
that you want me to give you my yeah
your opinion if the world unites
china's in trouble i think that's their
achilles heel if the world unites
china's in trouble
if the world realizes they don't if the
world finds a different place to produce
chips if the world produ
finds a different place to produce the
80 of pharmaceuticals if the world finds
a different place to produce the ac the
everything that they produce over there
if the world realizes they don't need
china and that shifts from china to
india china's screwed yeah by the way
india has more resources more natural
resources india has the same amount of
people give or take 100 million
less india is the education is getting
better with
the engineers that produce them with the
tech with the direction they're going
into
india's got a lot of stuff now obviously
they're a decade behind china maybe even
two decades behind china
and they don't have the same
infrastructure maybe not two decades but
they don't have the infrastructure that
china has
but if all of a sudden the world gets
behind india instead of getting behind
china
i don't think china is going to be up i
think secretly china's afraid of the
world uniting and china's afraid of the
world leaning and giving the business to
india instead of giving it to china
yeah i don't think they like that yeah i
agree with you i i think the threat for
china is within and it's all about the
economy
and you know china is ahead of india
right now because they stole all our
secrets i mean that was part of their
strategy they
look at what we do and they copy it i
think we could help
india close that gap pretty quickly like
if we collaborated with them with our
breath
our best and brightest and you know help
them advance technology
you know with everything that they're
doing look and they have a much
much more progressive leader in that
country that's uh an ally of ours so
modi you're saying yeah yeah but listen
that's what i would say i think they
if the if they think that for a second
the world is looking at india and bro
doing deals with
india they're they're not happy about it
well it's not just india it's taiwan
taiwan philippines it's uh vietnam it's
uh
cambodia everything in the i don't know
japan
yeah all of that is fine yeah and i'm
with you there but
india could be india is the big direct
threat yeah a direct threat look who
they took shots at on weibo
they took shots at india when india had
the covet stuff taking through the 400
000 cases a day for seven days they took
shots at india they made fun of india
the politicians at the top
made fun of india who who do people
typically make fun of their number one
competitor
exactly people that are in their head in
their head i think india's in the head
of china and that may be wrong
obviously india has come out and banned
a lot of uh the social platform
exactly 100 different apps have been uh
platformed in india and china they're
they're when you're headed for a
collision when you have a billion people
you have power
i mean you just do so we'll see there's
only two countries that have that so
there's a direct uh battle going on for
that anyways
let's do a fun story here disneyland is
about to introduce 100 sandwich okay
kai if you want to pull up the picture
here if you have it disney is
introducing
a hundred dollar sandwich so when i
heard this story i said you got to be
kidding me
disneyland is an introducing 100
sandwich as a fox business story
yes what's the sandwich look like so
here's what it is real quick we'll spend
two minutes on this disney resort will
come out
uh soon and they're opening up anaheim
california resort will have a new panini
sandwich that will be debuting when
avenge
avengers campus opens at disneyland
adventures on june 4th
the sandwich has an eye popping price
tag of a hundred dollars to be fair to
sand which is meant to be eaten by more
than one person
so what's in the sandwich that cost this
much money it comes with salami
rosemary ham provolone and sun-dried
tomatoes spread on toasted
focaccia and focaccia and
can feed up to eight people the sandwich
will also be available in single serving
of 15 bucks can we see what the sandwich
looks like can you imagine a hundred
dollar sandwich in disneyland it does
look like it's a panini
yeah i don't know i just kind of feel
like i'm so at this point i'm getting
hungry and hungry it's 10 30.
yeah and i thought that was a quick
story yeah any thoughts on that i have
some thoughts
i'm looking forward to their very
controversial story yourself i'm looking
forward to their 435 dollar chicken
nugget i mean i heard that is amazing
they also have a 200 hot dog bun but
here's my favorite the 130 dollar
parking fee
oh wait they already have that you know
it totally makes it
really well it feels like that when you
go there which is it actually
can i give everybody the secret to do at
disney yes you learned this when you
live
go to downtown disney right where the
bars are you know where the restaurants
are
valet right okay and then just go in and
have a drink before you walk into
disneyland
so you can dilute the paint a little bit
that you're going to feel walking around
with your kids for the next couple hours
that's our strategy
valet park drink before you go in and
then it makes it a lot more enjoyable by
the way i think it's a brilliant idea to
have 100
sandwich because it takes the sting off
the increased ticket prices
the 12 bottle of water it just skews
perspective how much is tickets right
now disneyland probably
what 100 i would imagine maybe even more
right yeah
i mean they got to make up for some lost
time anybody knows kai do you have an
idea or no adam you
i know you're big on that so are you you
got disneyland ticket prices or no
i'm saying 150 bucks yeah this is what
is it by the way i'm actually curious at
this point
i think it's like 159 bucks if you ask
me i don't know why i think it's 159
there it is okay 104. it's
the price is for a number of days one
day is 104 what are you looking at
it's one day tier five
one park per day okay 104 dollars okay
not a bad price if you ask me not about
98 a child okay that's what's expensive
right there but ninety dollars a child
we got a couple kids i'll tell you what
i'd rather do a seventy two dollar
haircut than a hundred dollar sandwich
any day of the week wow would you really
though yeah
so you mean to tell me you wouldn't
wanna have a hundred dollar panini with
kai
with paul with mario with eric would
you wouldn't want to do that with your
boys that's a man witch right that's a
man witch right there i'm good on that
okay let's continue let's continue let's
continue tim cook
defense apple in blockbuster fortnite
trial it has nothing to do with money
page five if you want to go to it so
this was going on a few months ago but
the story's back he was in court this
week in his first ever court appearance
as ceo of apple on friday tim cook
sought to defend the tech giant from
allegations that it abuses its market
power by touting
it as a principal company with an
obsessive focus on users the iphone
makers chief executive took the stand to
wrap up apple's case on his highest
profile anti-trust trial with epic games
at the center of the lawsuits at 4
as fortnite the highly hugely popular
video game made by epic that was kicked
out of apple's app store last summer by
for flooring
flouting uh apple's rules of digital
payments by establishing its own system
apple gets 30
cut of many in-app purchases on ios
devices and does not allow alternative
payment solutions fortnite removal from
the app store prompted epic to sue apple
apple is focused on doing what's best
for users rather than any
financial benefits cook said when asked
by epic
epic's lawyer where the apple is
considering the revenue in excess of 100
million dollars in commissions it
receives from epic and fortnite
he said the user is caught between two
companies
it has nothing to do with money do you
agree let me tell you something yes
anytime someone says this is an old
adage everyone knows this
anyone someone says it's not about the
money it's about the motherflipping
money okay it always is
yeah there it is it's about the money
i'm gonna make a prediction and as we
all know
my predictions are never wrong who
predicted that
trump would be state it would be uh stay
off facebook i have a hot winning streak
right now here's my next
i'm going to have your check i'm going
to have to check uh win streak
yeah it's recent okay well you know
don't even get me started on zenner's
prediction apple is winning
this lawsuit 100 it's over they're in
closing arguments right now there's no
way they lose
apple wins 100 by the way that was the
first time tim cook has ever appeared in
court as the ceo of apple here's what i
think he should do i think he should do
an an nft on his appearance in court
sell that sucker to cover any court
costs in case things do go sideways nft
you know what i'm going to give you my
personal opinion on this it's not based
on anything about this court case i hope
fortnite loses i don't like them i don't
like companies that build their games to
get
kids addicted and that's what they do so
i got a problem with them i want apple
to win now let me
ask you this let me ask you this
question would dash be upset with that
comment hell no because a he's never
going to play it has he has he played
for
never he's never oh my god he will not
be alone tell me why not because we
don't let him play games what if he's 28
years old
well then i won't yeah you don't know
what's happening when we met dash he was
walking around tonight
when we met dash he was walking around
the streets doing whatever he wanted to
do
freely freely 10 year old kid just
walking the streets of manhattan beach
you don't think he's going to his
homie's house playing video games
don't tell my dad tom sanders for me not
being able to do this
you tom you know this you prevent your
kid from doing something he's going to
do it on the low
i cannot wait to see and how old is he
right now 13 or 14. he's 12. he's 12. i
can't wait the next 18 years
to see the list of girlfriends dash is
going to happen i'm actually being
serious with him i already got 10. no no
no but i'm looking for when he's 18.
i want tom's going to say patty want to
see dash's latest girlfriend send me the
picture i'm like i'm not i believe it
you know what i'm worried about
i'm making a prediction here it is dash
don't listen to this podcast that's not
good for you when you got double d
connecting you've got dash and dilly boy
over there connecting
dash and dylan that's a that's a
difficult duo right there
you gotta scar this one you know what
dilly did to me last night he says dad
look at this i can raise one of my
eyebrows
and he started doing one he started the
one just like you have to see how he
does it he's i don't know i'm like
where'd you pick it up from says no i
was looking at the mirror that and i can
erase only one of my eyebrows look at
the way i do it
it goes like this it's i gotta post it
to see it it's that smooth dude
we're all in favor of our kids having
more friends with private jets so i hope
they can get together
we also have a friend that can do the
little eyebrow thing her name is
caroline she did the
eyebrow oh she can do it she was giving
vanessa the the i heard the one eyebrow
i heard she beat you in pink
which which was like she's she's a she's
a liar
she's a i heard that you were
considering cutting off your thumb in
order to beat me in pinkbone that's not
the thumbnail index finger
this finger gets in the way this whole
time i thought it was the thumb this
whole time
it was your index finger all right maybe
we got to go live maybe we got to go
best out of five and we go live and hold
on he sees to see who's a better player
let me do the play by
you're actually better than me by five
points would you agree
to four to five four to five points 16
21 17 21 it is what it is it is what it
is but
okay so next story next story do we want
to do the
netflix story or the kgb story which
story do you want to go to how about we
talk about the buying home pan go to
page three
go to page three go to page three this
is good because the real estate people
are going to love this one
yes this is why you got to buy a house
right now yeah right to all the realtors
out there this is a story for you
people are panic buying homes as prices
skyrocket around the world a cnn
business story
house prices have soared even as the
world suffered its worst slump since the
great depression from new zealand to
united states to germany china peru
the same phenomenon has taken hold home
prices are skyrocketing and many buyers
are panicking
amongst the 37 wealthy countries that
make up the organization for economic
cooperation
and development the oecd real house
prices rose by almost seven percent
between the fourth quarter of 2019
and the fourth quarter of 2020 the
fastest year-on-year growth
in the past two decades in the united
states the number of sales existing
homes
reached the highest level in 2020 since
2006 according to the national associate
of
real realtors house prices rose 9
in 2020 and i've continued to climb with
the median price of existing home
hitting a historic high of three hundred
twenty nine thousand uh hundred dollars
in march
in one staggering example of how
frenzied the house market has become the
realtor ellen coleman received
76 all cash offers on a
270 000
fixer upper and suburban square foot
home sold 460 thousand dollars
of washington dc within three days of
listing the property let me say this one
more time 76
all cash offers on a 75 000
fix a fixer-upper in dc the four-bedroom
1800 square foot home
sold for 460 000. a
70 increase on asking price ridiculous
so this was a 275 thousand dollar
fixer-upper sold for 460.
which the the amazing thing about that
is you could understand it for a 20
million dollar house right because you
got a billionaire buying it and they
don't care what's a few extra millions
but look at this thing this is this is a
conservative house you know this is
nothing
fancy what's the value gonna be if the
market tanks for them that was quite a
risk and by the way my sister and
brother-in-law
are moving to d.c so i hope they can
find a house it looks like it's really
really tough and competitive out there
you know i've heard of panic buying when
it comes to toilet paper
when it comes to paper towels when it
comes to hand sanitizer maybe plywood
before a hurricane
i get that yeah but hey honey how was
your day well i drove by a realtor's
office and i
picked up a two-story rambler and a
condo i'm stocking up because of the
pandemic
i don't get the pan i don't get the
panic buying when it comes to real
estate i don't get it the only thing
i can see is the fact that inflation is
coming
at crazy measures it's the only thing i
see
is that inflation's coming and they're
getting to a point where powell is
sitting there wondering what the hell
does he do he has to increase the rates
but if he increases the rates what
happens he has no choice but to have to
increase the rates
how much longer can you go keeping it
under one percent for this long
you can he has to increase it when he
does just so you know
it ain't going to be the same community
as we have right now right inflation is
going to go up
and some people are looking at it long
term as the best place to put it is real
estate
some people actually think the people i
feel sorry for and i'll let you go adam
is the people that
got in this late as realtors i bet there
was a lot of people that saw the frenzy
in the real estate
market and thought i'm going to be a
realtor they get their license they get
in late
yeah right because you got to have some
contacts and experience but you become a
realtor in three months when the thing
tanks
there's gonna be a lot of people in the
wrong industry you talked about that
there's a million realtors
and those 1.5 million realtors and
there's only a million houses for sale
something like 1 million 435 000
realtors 1 million 90
000 homes for sale so let me you you
actually brought up a good point the
panic buying on the toilet paper the
panic buying that we saw a couple weeks
ago on the gasoline
now we're seeing the panic buying of
homes
just to read the headline again people
are panicked buying homes
as prices skyrocket around the world let
me just give read you a couple of the
highlighted words that i've read just
from this article
panic frenzied highest level historic
highs
skyrocketing soaring fastest growth
that's never a good time to be going all
in on a certain asset class
i don't think people are buying houses
because they're worried about inflation
i think they're saying people are buying
now i gotta buy i gotta buy i gotta buy
this it's time to buy we gotta buy it
yeah
and they have no clue what they're
getting themselves into two-thirds of
millennials basically
had remorse or regret about buying a
house half of baby boomers
buying a house is ain't exactly all that
it's cracked up to be you think that
you're
only paying your mortgage payment we
talked about your big three expenses
when it comes to
having home ownership your maintenance
your taxes and your insurance and people
don't account for that
so pump the brakes if you're in the
housing market i think
that christ prices are going to crash
over the next couple how much how big of
a crash is
20 oh you think 20 percent yeah you
think 20 percent
yes in the next 12 months that's not i
don't know in the next few years that's
like a weight right i mean that
no no no not 08 was way more than 20 i
want to say
and and no in some some parts of the
country it was like i think
in l.a riverside county was a 60 drop
off yes but in texas it was a 10 or 50
drop off they didn't have a big drop-off
so some states are
is going to be higher than others
california usually takes it worse when
there is a
big drop off you know another thing here
too is i think people were panic buying
because
of the lockdown and they're thinking i
got to have a home office yeah right i'm
going to be
i'm not going to be commuting as much
i'm going to be home but now the
country's opening up you're not gonna be
working hopefully at a home
you know unless china sends another
virus over here allegedly
but so that's another reason they were
fixing up their homes they wanted bigger
home offices to work out of there
etc okay all right well we'll see what's
going to happen with that
we will see what's going to happen with
that netflix ceo gives 3 million dollars
to beat
newsome recall not to beat newsome but
to beat
the recall there's a big difference
right so let's see why
netflix ceo is doing this so netflix seo
gives three million dollars to beat the
news
recall it's a political story uh he is
spending three million dollars to shield
governor newsom from a recall vote and
demonstration of the enormous sum uh
some nuisance allies could marshal in
his defense according to state filing
the massive outlay making hastings
by far the largest donor to the new
son's recall campaign on the california
rules newsom can raise unlimited sums to
fend off a recall effort
that will likely land before voters in
the fall
while other gubern governor candidates
are subject to
campaign limits of thirty two thousand
four hundred dollars per election in
their direct accounts the hasting
contribution can punctuate
uh also punctuates a dramatic reversal
since newsom
ran for governor in 2018 hastings that
you report
seven million dollars into a charter
school driven political action committee
that supported newsome's democratic
rival former los angeles mayor
antonio villagrosa interesting so he
gave seven million dollars
to antonio tech leaders had already
signed on to a letter posing the recall
and pledging that their support to
pledging their support for new thoughts
my thoughts are that he's probably
thinking that if there's a republican
governor in california it might be
somebody like desantis that declares war
on tech companies which would directly
affect him
so he's going to do everything he can to
prevent that you know
i live there there's no momentum for any
candidate whatsoever
john cox is the former mayor of san
diego san diego that's supposed to be
one of the big names throwing his hat in
the ring he just puts seven million of
his own money into his own campaign you
don't see any ads
you don't hear anything there's no
there's no energy for anybody
unfortunately i think
you know newsome got very very lucky you
know uh california with all the tax
revenue
has helped him people are have short
memories you know they're thinking okay
it's better now it's opening up we'll
just go with what we have
now i read in the la times today that
there's a chance
because of the blackouts that could be
happening this summer i mean we're gonna
have a ton of fires again and then the
the
you know the grid in california has a
real hard time keeping up with the
electricity demands when the
when the weather goes up if there's a
lot of blackouts that could affect him
as well
but in order for newsome to lose there
has to be somebody that you want in
there and i just don't see anybody
having any momentum yet and by the way
he's not going to be the only
one you have unlimited funds that you
can use in a recall election there's no
limit on your war chest j.j abrams has
pledged money
uh i saw the ceo of the 49ers you got
the labor unions law firms
sending big bucks newsom's way so i but
if you ask me about
reed hastings i think it has to do
something with protecting his business
yeah so you don't think our good friend
major williams that you're on the
podcast love
major will yeah you don't think he might
have a chance well 2022 i think he also
is thinking in the back of his mind
that's a good start well it's just gonna
be tough for anybody
and then you also got this guy meet
kevin who came out there and he was a
20-point plan he's talking about running
but basically i think ultimately what
you're saying is nobody has
the wind behind them that has any chance
of beating
newsome especially when you have big
tech rallying behind him and he has
unlimited sums of money whereas i guess
other candidates
are subject to campaign limits of 32 000
per election
versus unlimited funds money talks baby
and it seems like newsome's got the
money
i got a crazy quote i just searched it
right now i didn't know this what do you
think is the age to become a governor
president is what
35 30. it's not it's not it varies by
state
fyi okay most states
is 30 most the highest one matter of
fact
nobody has it above 30 just so you know
every state is highest
30. what do you think california is 34.
18. i'm telling you california ohio i'm
looking at it right now california ohio
uh rhode island and washington and
wisconsin are the five states where to
be a governor is 18 years old which
means
do you think a guy like meet kevin he's
a hustler he's hungry he goes after it
he's not afraid
he's he's very good on camera great very
well spoken understands
money has strong opinions do you think a
guy like that could be a governor in the
state of
california a young guy like me kevin if
he's going against newsome zero chance
zero chance against news tell me why
well against newsome
tell me why tell me why tell me why
newsome clearly has big tech behind it
okay what else okay so he called that
instagram right he's calling he sent me
a message the other day saying hey
you know i've been following your
content he's been following
valuetainment since a thousand
subscribers i said listen i love your
stuff as well
you're killing it so i follow him on
instagram because i like what he's doing
i would love to see a young cat like
that
come up out of nowhere and by the way
whether he wins or not
do you know how much energy it takes to
make a run for governor like how much
energy every day all day every day i
think
a young guy with a lot of energy by the
way my friend steve just sent me a text
message
right now okay and guess what the text
message is about
it's a text message he sent about meet
kevin
i got it at 10 19 which is 30 minutes
ago right meet kevin and he says i like
what he's talking about with newsome now
steve lives in california right
there are a lot of people that are
hoping somebody like him
comes up and makes a move and i think a
young guy with a lot of energy in a
state like california that's 18 years
old to run for governor and he's got a
few million subscribers
go at it i'd love to see what happens
let me clarify my statements do i think
he's got upside
sure but he can be newsom not not this
time around not even close well here
not even close this time give me your
percentage likewise
number less than zero this time around
i'm not talking about four years i'm not
talking about it eight years
kevin if you're talking about this time
around i would tell you to go
slash his tires but he doesn't have a
car he doesn't have a car he would have
to slash all the uber drivers
he's going to knock on the young man
meet kevin i think i want kevin i want
you to take it as a knife okay
i want you to take this clip and take it
as a knife go ahead kevin go ahead i'd
love to have him on
no chance at all this time around let me
be a voice of reason once again
let me help you out me kevin
flip-flopper over here voice of reason
oh i am a voice
without you going to the business hey
listen guys meet kevin has a legitimate
chance and i'll tell you why because uh
someone that can rally people on social
media is like being a celebrity
what happened the last time an upset
happened in a recall election a
celebrity wanted
look what happened did you guys hear
what happening in huntington beach this
past weekend there was a tick tock
birthday party on the beach in
huntington beach
and and every single jurisdiction in
orange county had to send
cops there they arrested 1500 people it
was so out of control
and it was because of social media you
telling me a guy like me kevin couldn't
get a little
momentum going online build it turning
it into an army of followers i don't
know his policies has he posted anything
with his policies
there was a 20 point plan can you
respond
let's just see what he has up there on
his website i don't know his policies
let's uh the kid if he if he's if yeah
he'll click on that let's go to
he's interested in running for politics
i think he's got an upside not against
no
go lower go lower kevin okay there it is
right there
all right let's see meet kevin go a
little lower go a little lower
no state income tax on the first quarter
million dollars of income interest
removes the california okay hang on
everyone's going to have a quarter
million no california tax return
required and approximately five to seven
percent flat tax on income above
quarter million dollars okay okay fair
keep going number two homeless emergency
housing uh for all homelessness within
60 days of emergency powers medical and
substance mental
is available three meals per day in
centralization and then no one lives on
the streets in our state anymore within
60 days
okay i vote for him right now on that
one point i don't care about anything
how much money he needs to do that
though to say that is a different story
than coming up with the money especially
after you just tom you have all the
taxes you just got taxed
so future schools seven percent 14 years
old students have a choice to attend a
future school combines
college trade high school and financial
kids and students graduates
in partnership with small medium and
large business throughout california
okay cool i like that the future the
housing emergency
uh we have unaffordable rents and
housing due to a lack of homes instead
of 80
000 new units per year california v
emergency powers will build
500 000 new housing units per year for
five years state will control all
buildings and
trends one okay fine go to the next one
uh the transportation emergency request
proposals
private sector to solve transportation
emergency optional variable uh tall
roads new roads in addition to existing
roads with tolls
giving drivers the option to make a toll
road or not more roads equals less
traffic
okay keep going uh legally legalizing
gamble okay we'll stop uh supporting
tunnels
and roads to new communities via
construction boom okay
six uh legalizing gambling legalize
online and in-person gambling bill
casinos throughout california five to
ten billion tax revenue expected from
construction bailouts
build outs uh prevents returning uh to
state income taxes okay and i think that
that could be interesting i just don't
know
the the the uh the the indian
reservation like there's a
there's some challenges you're gonna
face with that today millions leave
california to try vacation gamble
elsewhere why not do this
yeah i agree they're going right next
door to him which is where nevada right
no more blackouts this is going to be a
big one you were talking about the
blackouts
can you tell the audience why blackout's
a big deal because you know it shuts
down
they do these rolling blackouts and it
shuts down the energy uh your
electricity goes out it happened to us
last week twice what does this mean
blackouts like flat out blackouts yeah
yeah we're the only california
yeah because there's so much pressure on
the grid when the temperatures are up
and
people are maxing their air conditioning
that they have to shut it down how long
does it go out
uh hours generally not much more than
that but hours
like hours is a long time a long time so
hours without ac
sure absolutely so no more blockages
plus the power companies are responsible
for most of these fires anyway it
happens right underneath their power i
lived in california but that was six
years ago five and a half years ago i
don't remember a lot of black guys
it's gotten worse with the fighters yeah
all right no more blackouts more people
plans okay future
uh courts small claims uh limits raised
to a hundred thousand dollars new small
claims advisor
spending legalism by missing our courts
okay nine transforming the dmv and
virtual ids virtual ids and registration
with qr codes well i i got
i disagree with that the dvd or the uh
dmv is awesome in california no change
necessary it's perfect why is he
i'm joking oh my gosh i was gonna say i
have like 20 stories for you from a dmv
by the one time i was at the dmv and
right in front of me i'm like is this
who i think it is it was dr dre we were
in line for like 30 minutes we had a
great conversation
i said so you also got to get a license
yeah i can't get away with that
there you go so number 10 future
policing and jails instant focus on
novak okay 11 underground high handy
person economy current law criminalizes
p
being a handy person immediately create
a handy personal license providing a
path to insurance online okay
cool 12 mandated local manufacturing
employment and
uh california hb1s h1bs uh
future money and exchanges gun safety
trading
trained gun owners are currently treated
like criminals in california this is
ridiculous
those who are trained and background
checks shall have more rights in
california
maximizing biden's funding uh via
schools and credits
thirty thousand twenty fifty dollars
okay got it funding housing ten percent
dollars
okay the carbon tax first state to
institute a carbon tax incentivizing
green energy punishes uh
uh uh but does not ban polluting
industries okay the green
wave allowing traffic alleviating
traffic go to the next one
day one executive action immigration
homelessness uh school and housing go to
number 20. let's see what number 20 is
california transition bond or emergency
and so on okay i mean we'll see what's
going to happen there he seems like he's
got a plan
so i'm i'm curious to know what happens
all i'm saying is
i would love to see some young folks
with a lot of energy
to go out there and push their weight
around they're going to be bullied i'm
not surprised if meat kevin's going to
be bullied
he's going to be challenged he's going
to be pushed around people are going to
laugh at him there's no way this can
happen all this other stuff
i also think on the flip side he's going
to also be able to create some momentum
yeah there's a market for common sense
right now and i think if you could speak
that people might not admit it but they
will
rally and support him all right i think
it's interesting that when major
williams is on here you said i have an
idea for you you should start
implementing the phrase try
me yeah and on every social media post
he hashtagged
i love it try me so shout out to me i
would love to see
more of those guys creating momentum and
challenge in the status quo
totally agree about it behind newsom
he's not going to get recalled yeah
there is one story i want to get into
there's one story i want to get into
okay then we go to pelosi try to
sabotage green new deal rollout over
fears of aoc this is this is
this is actually very interesting go to
page seven folks um
we got five minutes left i'm probably
gonna do one last one here because we've
already done six or seven i said we're
gonna do one two or three
you give a super chat whatever you give
ten times more we're gonna give it back
to you i think we've already given two
thousand dollars
two thousand at least two thousand
dollars we've given away so if you give
a hundred bucks i like it
i'm gonna start leaving comments over
here i go to page uh go to page
uh go to page seven go to page seven
say that again all these payments are
being handed out in quarters right
where is my course where it's written
for my quarters by the way ricky's new
episode's going out on valuetainment
spanish here soon so if you like
ricky's stuff seriously we got five
minutes before i jump on the zoom so
let's go through this here we go
pelosi tried to sabotage green new deal
rollout over fears of
aoc new book this is a fox news story
house speaker nancy pelosi tried to
sabotage the roll out a representative
alexander ocasio-cortez green new deal
in 2019 because she was anxious about
the new congresswoman's
notoriety becoming actual power
according to a new book about the
insider democratic politics obtained by
fox news in february 2019 pelosi called
massachusetts
senator ed markey the night before he
was scheduled to help roll out the green
new deal she asked him to hold off she
wanted more substantive policy
the politics weren't good right then
don't give the platform to ocasio-cortez
she urged anxious about the new
congresswomans notoriety become an
actual power
edward isaac dover rights in battle for
the soul inside the democrats campaign
to defeat trump
the green new deal rollout formally
outlined the proposal in congress for
the first time
and would mark a start on the path
towards what aoc called a wartime
level just economic mobilization plan to
get to 100 renewable energy
cost estimates for the sprawling
proposal ranging to the trillions
dover's book will be published on
tuesday so
aoc was concerned about i'm sorry pelosi
was concerned about aoc creating
momentum
yeah you know she's old school man this
is my house speaker of the house
i finally found one reason to like nancy
pelosi you know she's going to
laying the hammer down there that book
has got so many explosive findings in it
that's the book that has
obama ripping trump obama swearing at
the media obama's got a pretty filthy
mouth
if you read this book you're going to be
blown away how much that guy swears
that's what trump will do to obama get
him get him
person oh well well this is just a
classic case of reality versus
fantasyland
as say what you want to about uh nancy
pelosi she's been doing this for 40
years
at least she's living in reality where
aoc is just
fantasyland over here with her trillion
dollar green no deal
and this is nervous nancy basically
saying pump the brakes on aoc
uh that woke cancel culture leftist
movement on the left of the democratic
party
they don't exactly uh have a lot of
substance to their numbers i don't think
uh
alexandra ocasio-cortez has been in
power what two
three years now this is her second term
right now
and uh i don't think she understands how
budgeting works and that's the problem
that she's gonna face
but she does have upside if she actually
learns math she's a dangerous
political figure oh my let me ask you a
couple questions who's more attractive
more pelosi i mean come on it's not even
a question okay
all right who's got a bigger following
on twitter it's not even a comparison
seven million aoc it just so you know i
said pelosi is what seven million aoc is
at
uh uh uh uh come on aoc where are you at
aoc is at 12.7 million okay who's better
at rallying aoc or pelosi aoc aoc
who who's who understands understands
social media better aoc or pelosi
who who's more uh marketable long-term
aos or pelosi
who's a better sales person aoc or
pelosi who's
you want to keep going like you talked
about with china and india you attack
people who are threatening you pelosi is
clearly threatened by aoe
exactly and she is more marketable
i don't agree with her policies but she
is a much better politician than
pelosi although pelosi is a dirtier
politician behind closed doors because
she's been around longer
so she's got the entire playbook of
seven whatever 50 years she's been into
politics
she knows all the playbooks versus new
schools i still think it was she's going
to end up beating her long term if you
ask me
oh yeah i think nancy's retiring after
this uh it's a clearly
long term yes yes that's the upside okay
so i think we went through it uh
uh gang this was uh uh probably one of
my favorite podcasts we've done a lot
of steve appreciate steven they did a
great job uh
on the debate if you enjoyed this format
and if you want to
if you want me to continue the super
chat model of 10 times
please subscribe to the channel give us
a thumbs up and click on that
notification button so youtube notifies
you
when we're going up with the podcast and
then last but not least kai who's on on
thursday who's on thursday do we know
who's on thursday podcast
we don't know yet okay we'll be
announcing who's on thursday anyways
we look forward to seeing you join us
again this thursday
we are on though yes or no we are doing
podcast thursday same time take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you